We have a voicemail number. That number is
two one nine two David P.. Every few months,
the San Antonio troll comes out of the woodwork
and this guy has been calling in for years at this
point. And what I love about this caller is almost
every time he calls in, he criticizes me for
something I haven't even talked about, and he's
doing that again today. And what's really funny
is some of what he mentions I haven't talked about
some of what he mentions. I haven't even heard
about. I don't know what he's talking about here.
Listen to this, Pacman. I think I've solved
it. I have solved why? Why you, Don Lemon,
Joy? They are Hilmar Varsh, all the same talk,
you all have the same kind of exactly. Politics.
OK, I figured out why spawned by the way, Bill
Maher and Bosh do not have the same politics.
OK, let's continue to wait for one. None of you
are talking about why the 15 million minimum
wage is getting there, kicking the can to
twenty, twenty five. None of you spoke about
that. But instead, we're worried about
who's starring in the next 60 plus film.
I've never I don't know. I didn't even know there
was a controversy about the next Disney plus
film in a Superman interview.
Black is this.
I didn't even hear about anything about
Superman being black. These are stories
I haven't even heard of. Never mind
talked about. Why is he calling me?
He should be calling people who talked about
it like Colin Kaepernick and Nike shoes.
I figured out why we're more worried about that
than actual workers getting a fair wage. Because
you're rich and you don't love your own money. Who
cares of working people, your wages. But Disney,
that's a yo yo like this because of Netflix. So
it's important that they have the Disney plus.
I don't know what he's talking about.
No nonwhite actors. And so, like, I get it.
But man, do we really need money, man.
We're supposed to release your boy, buddy.
I, i and it's funny. He's acting like I'm talking
about Disney plus and not covid relief. Whoo hoo!
On the left has been more critical of the delay on
this than I have. I mean, I'm sure lots of people
are being critical, but we've been following
the delays on capitally from day one. We've been
covering the watering down of covid really from
day one. I think this guy's got the wrong show.
No, we're excited. They keep pushing.
Is delaying this and that. I'm with you.
Twenty, twenty, twenty, twenty, twenty
five. And it's a thousand dollars down
tubes. It's the same thing and it's you guys
keep making excuses, but it's there on your.
I've made no excuses.
You know, the most important
thing in the world is Disney plus Netflix.
Yeah. So that's the San Antonio troll.
And you know, I wish he does he does
things a lot of people don't do.
He's audible in the voice mails. A lot of people
calling. You can't hear what they're saying.
He gets right to the point. A lot of people call
in. They go three minutes. And before they even
get to the point, the voicemail system, the
San Antonio troll could be a good caller,
but he's criticizing me for things that I've
never even talked about and sometimes that I
don't even know about. It's sad to sad state
of affairs. We've got a great bonus show for
you today. Mike Pence finally breaks his silence
and he's criticizing the twenty twenty election.
We will talk about why some U.S. Catholic
bishops are discouraging parishioners from
getting the Johnson and Johnson vaccine.
We will also talk about parler suing Amazon
again and what's going on with that.
All of those stories and more on today's
bonus show. Get instant access by signing up
at Join Pakman Dotcom. The coupon code remains
available. The coupon code is better. Twenty
one all one word could be lower case. You could
spell it all caps. You could alternate.
It's not case sensitive, but it is all
one word better. Twenty one at join Pakman
dot com. I'll see you on today's bonus show.